[Music]
we like to think of America as the land
of the free but this year over half of
our state legislature introduced laws
discriminating against lgbtq people
unfortunately making laws that Target
queer people isn't new It's actually an
American tradition I'll explain in a
segment called how did we get here
in the past few years Republican
politicians have basically declared war
on lgbtq Americans this includes
everything from Florida's don't say gay
Bill to Arizona trying to ban books that
depict homosexuality to Texas asking
private citizens to report the parents
of trans kids for child abuse now I hate
even saying those things it feels like
they're pulled off of something called
Satan's to-do list
it's the same list that includes make
eye drops and super glue bottles look
exactly the same and make all Walgreens
stores play Chumbawamba
because
our government isn't just reflecting
American homophobia they're also
creating it and it's happened before the
FBI and the federal government have a
long history of monitoring outing and
criminalizing queer Americans so let's
go back to the 1930s to give you an idea
how long ago that was it was literally
when they invented sliced bread that's
true before that you had to eat the
whole loaf like corn on the cob
now in 1936 a boy named Charles Matson
was kidnapped and eventually killed it
was tragic and the case was all over the
news the FBI was under a lot of pressure
to solve it then a random informant told
the FBI that the crime looked like it
had been done by a sexual deviate or
sexual pervert now those were euphemisms
they used back then for gay people like
how now when someone is pregnant we say
they have a bun in the oven or when
they're unemployed we say they're an
influencer now
the FBI never solved Matt since
kidnapping and never had any actual
evidence that a gay man was involved but
by spreading the rumor that Matson was
kidnapped by a gay man they started a
campaign of homophobia that still Echoes
today
it's worth mentioning that in those days
the FBI was headed by J Edgar Hoover who
many historians believe was a closeted
gay man now was Hoover straight in
making homophobic laws that reflected
the culture around him was he gay and
motivated by internal isomophobia did
the J stand for jingles
those are things we will never know for
sure the only thing we do know is
straighter gay Jingles was a [ __ ]
the FBI the FBI secretly started
monitoring gay people and began a
campaign to make Americans believe that
queer people were preying on children
and even weirder working as spies for
the Soviet Union which is ridiculous the
Soviet Union didn't have time to hire
gay people they were too busy giving
steroids to athletes
but the fear-mongering worked in 1950
Congress held a hearing called
homosexuals in government and shortly
after that J Edgar Hoover issued a memo
creating an FBI file to report any quote
sexual deviates who worked for the
government which is horrifying the only
time it's okay to keep a list of gay
people is if you're Santa Claus trying
to remember who gets Patty LuPone
tickets
Hoover's memo was the start of something
called the lavender scare which I wish
was a punk band Led by Grimace but
instead it was a period in American
history when a group of officials led by
senator Joseph McCarthy claimed the
government had been infiltrated by queer
people who had been blackmailed to
become spies and Communists and I know
that sounds like something a person in a
tinfoil hat would scream outside of TJ
Maxx but here's the thing it worked in
1953 President Eisenhower executed
executive order 10450 Banning gay people
from working for the government or its
contractors and countless employees who
were gay or suspected of being gay lost
their jobs that's an insane reason to be
fired this is America we only fire
people for good reasons like being
pregnant
well the lavender scare was a wonderful
idea and it led to great things just
kidding it was very bad and it sucked
and it ended in tragedy less than two
months after that executive order the
son of a democratic U.S senator named
Lester hunt was arrested on what they
called morals charges which was code for
we think he's gay Republican politicians
threatened to out Hunt's son unless the
senator resigned but he didn't resign
instead the senator killed himself
because that's what happens when
politicians demonize the queer Community
people get hurt and people get killed
which brings us back to today in the
1930s homophobia and transphobia was a
secret government operation now state
legislatures are doing it right out in
the open and they're using the same
tactics accusing queer people of hurting
children and having secret agendas when
the only agenda queer people have is to
be left alone and to make sure A League
of Their Own gets a season two
got it you gotta renew it you have to
but at the end of the day these bills
aren't really about lgbtq people they're
about politicians inciting bigotry
politicians are trying to turn lgbtq
people into a fake enemy for you to be
scared of and then they're saying vote
for me and I'll protect you from that
enemy I just made up and this is
well-worn lazy territory and it's how
they get votes politicians have tried to
make voters afraid of queer people black
people latinx people Muslim people and
now they're back to queer people do not
fall for it if you do you're dumber than
a guy eating bread like corn on the cob
this has been how did we get here
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]